[Music]
for example The Amazing Race that was
watching that show The Amazing Race yeah
I was checking it out I was just
watching it for a while and then I hit
the info button and it look at it said
it said greedy white people running yeah
look at this one it's called The
Bachelor we all know The Bachelor yeah
when I was watching that show like a
perv and then I hit the info button and
it said a man is pursued by beautiful
women who sadly grew up without father
watching dr. Phil I love my dr. Phil and
I was watching dr. Phil and then I
pushed the info button it said that
people share their problems with a guy
who can't solve them Undercover Boss I
was watching Undercover Boss yeah and
then I hit the info button and it said
workers too scared to admit they
recognize their 8:05
mr. stranger wearing wig and beard hey
oh no I DVR'd the New England Patriots
in the playoffs yeah and look at this I
hit the button and it said get close to
your TV you can hear the deflation hit
Celebrity Apprentice
I was watching Celebrity Apprentice and
I hit the info button and it said now
with no celebrities you and I hope you
there soon
I can't wait look at this NBC Nightly
News I was watching the NBC Nightly News
when I hit the info button and it said
Brian Williams still trying to forget
that image of his daughter getting her
salad toss it's the it's the cable
company that writes that yeah the cables
company's way out our job is to report
right on what has happened and we too
were shocked we were shocked it's a
hundred percent true that we were shot
we were shot yeah yeah hello fellow
innocent guy hmm
yes Millionaire Matchmaker watching
Millionaire Matchmaker gonna hit the
info button it said after five minutes
you'll know why these millionaires are
still single
Chicago Fire watching the show Chicago
Fire yep and then I hit the info button
and it said have you heard of a Great
Chicago Fire this isn't in
[Applause]
this is the okay this via mediocre
Chicago fire that's largely contained to
a kitchen botched I was watching botched
yeah and then I hit the info button and
it said reality show about plastic
surgery gone wrong that is somehow not
starring Bruce Jenner and then finally I
was watching The Cosby Show as I want to
do I hit the info button and it said
just pretend you haven't heard
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you